اقترح الرئيس البيلاروسيه الكسندر
لوكاشينكو هدنه بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا
دون حق تغيير مواقع القوات او نقل المعدات
والاسلحه وحذر لوكاشينكو من اندلاع حرب
عالميه ثالثه بحرائق نوويه واكد لوكاشينكو
ان روسيا دوله نوويه وستستخدم اكثر
الاسلحه رعبا اذا مهدد الوضع بانهيارها
ساحاول المخاطره باقتراح لوقف الاعمال
العسكريه واعلان هدنه دون حق تغيير مواقع
القوات او نقل المعدات والاسلحه اذا حاول
الغرب من جديد استخدام فتراته وقف
العمليات العسكريه لتعزيز نشاطه بالخداع
ستضطر روسيا لاستخدام انتاج مجمعها
الصناعي العسكري بالكامل وجيشها لمواجهه
تصعيد النزاع كذخيره الفوسفور واليورانيوم
المنظم واليورانيوم المخصم روسيا دوله
نوويه لا يمكن هزيمتها واذا ادركت ان
الوضع يهدد بانهيارها فستستخدم اكثر
الاسلحه رعبا
وقال رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو
انه جرى تفعيل المفاوضات مع الرئيس الروسي
اللاديمير بوتين بشان مساله اعاده السلاح
النوويه الى بيلاروسيا التي تخلت عنه في
تسعينيات القرن الماضي واكد لوكاشينكو في
كلمته السنويه الموجهه لشعبه ان هدفه من
طرح هذه المساله ليس تخويف او ابتزاز احد
وانما ضمان الامن والسلم لشعبه حسب تعبيره
الاوض
اع الرتو وباصرار المفاوضات مع الرئيس
الروسي
بشان مساله اعاده السلاح النووي الى
بيلاروسيا وعلى وجه التحديد اعاده السلاح
النووي الذي اخرج من البلاد في تسعينيات
القرن الماضي بموجب ضمانات بعدم فرض اي
عقوبات او ممارسه ضغوطات او دعم ثورات او
تنفيذ هجوم ولكن كل هذا انتهى وخرم املك
الحق في طرح سؤال بشان اعاده السلاح
النووي الذي وقع على سحبه من البلاد من
كان قبلي لا ارمي الى تخويف احد او اللجوء
الى الابتزاز اريد فقط ان اضمن امن
بيلاروسيا والسلامه للشعب البيلاروسي
وتعليقا على تصريحتي لوكاشينكو قالت
الرئاسه الروسيه ان من المرجح ان يناقش
الرئيس الروسي بلادي والرئيس البيلاروسيا
الكسندر
مبادره بيلاروسيا بشان اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان
استمرار العمليات العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا هو السبيل الوحيد لتحقيق اهداف
موسكو في الوقت الحالي واضاف الكريم في
بيان ان دعوات لنشر اسلحه نوويه في
اوكرانيا تخلق خطرا افتراضيا لا يمكن
لروسيا تجاهله وتابع البيان ان النقاشات
الدائره في الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان ارسال
قوات حفظ السلام الى اوكرانيا بالغه
الخطوره